[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend und
Willkommen an diesem Dienstag an meiner
Seite ist für den Sport Norbert Lehmann
einen schönen guten Abend
spricht von einer humanitären
wirtschaftlichen und ökologischen
Katastrophe
Milliarden Kubikmeter Wasser strömen ins
Tal Ukraine und Russen beschuldigen sich
gegenseitig den kachowka Damm zerstört
zu haben was wird aus den Menschen
entlang des nipos
die Ampel und die EU Asylpolitik die
grüne Basis macht Druck die Regierung
dürfe die Pläne für ein schärferes
Asylrecht nicht mittragen
und Rammstein die Fans und die nie
tuff-vorwürfe welche Folgen hat der
Skandal für die anstehenden Konzerte in
Deutschland
[Musik]
es sei ein Kriegsverbrechen und die
größte menschengemachte
Umweltkatastrophe seit Jahrzehnten das
sagt nicht nur die Ukraine auch
westliche Politiker sind überzeugt das
Moskau verantwortlich ist für die
Sprengung des kachowka Staudamms der
Kreml dagegen spricht von ukrainischer
Sabotage klar ist der Damm und das
dazugehörige Wasserkraftwerk sind
zerstört zahlreiche Ortschaften schon
überschwemmt dazu gleich mehr zunächst
hat Christina gröntgen wichtige Fakten
der kachowska Staudamm 30 Meter hoch und
3,2 km lang er liegt im Süden der
Ukraine im von Russland besetzten Teil
der Region
auf einer Länge von über 200 Kilometern
zwischen novakarovka und saporisa der
Stausee fast 18 Milliarden Kubikmeter
Wasser das sind knapp 40% des Wassers im
Bodensee mit dem dazugehörigen Kraftwerk
spielt er eine wichtige Rolle für
Landwirtschaft und Energieversorgung
das aufgestaute Wasser speist unter
anderem die Kühlsysteme des
Atomkraftwerks saporisia und es fließt
in den nordcremekanal der die gesamte
Halbinsel mit Wasser versorgt sinkt der
Pegelstand im Stausee wird das Wasser
knapp unterhalb des Darms führt der
Bruch zu Überschwemmungen diese
Simulation schwedischer Experten zeigt
wie sich die Wassermassen über die
Region herson ausbreiten könnten
und aktuelle Daten zeigen dass das
Wasser noch schneller steigen könnte als
angenommen Christian Volk berichtet
seit den frühen Morgenstunden wälzen
sich die Wassermassen vorbei am
zerstörten karowka Staudamm
unkontrollierbar entlang des nipro
steigt der Wasserspiegel innerhalb von
kurzer Zeit um mehrere Meter an hunderte
Häuser sind überschwemmt knapp 40.000
Menschen betroffen auch in herzogen
das ist eine Katastrophe ich lebe etwas
weiter außerhalb und bei den Nachbarn
sind die Häuser schon überflutet das
Wasser wird noch drei vier Tage
ansteigen niemand weiß wie hoch
mittlerweile sind nach ukrainischen
Angaben mindestens 150 Tonnen Motoröl in
den knipro geflossen Kiew macht Russland
für den zerstörten Dampf verantwortlich
russland hat eine ökologische
Massenvernichtungswaffe gezündet der
Staudamm war von den Russen vermiet und
sie haben ihn in die Luft gejagt
auch Militärexperten halten das für
wahrscheinlich in der jetzigen Situation
der möglichen Offensive hat das
russische Militär offensichtlich die
teuflische Entscheidung getroffen um zu
verhindern dass die Ukraine hier im
Süden ansetzen diesen dann zu zerstören
so scheint es zumindest und daraus
können wir schließen dass es so
möglicherweise hier versucht wird quasi
nachhaltig die Einsatzführung der
europäischen Armee zu behindern oder zu
verhindern immer wieder explodieren
weggespülte Minen wenn sie gegen Bäume
oder Steine prallen Bundeskanzler Scholz
spricht von einer neuen Dimension
gleichzeitig passe der Vorfall zum
bisherigen russischen vorgehen und das
ist ja auch etwas das sich einreiten
viele viele der Verbrechen die wir in
der Ukraine gesehen haben die von
russischen Soldaten ausgegangen sind und
in einer Art der gehört zu einer
Kriegsführung die immer auch zivile
Ziele im Städte Dörfer Krankenhäuser
Schulen Infrastrukturen
angegriffen hat Moskau weist die
Vorwürfe zurück macht die Ukraine für
den Dammbruch verantwortlich
vor allem die Russisch besetzte Seite
des nipro ist überschwemmt die
Wasserversorgung zur Krim durch den
Vorfall abgeschnitten das Atomkraftwerk
saporisch ja das normalerweise mit
Wasser aus dem Stausee gekühlt wird sei
aber sicher so die internationale Atom
Energiebehörde
Tim Krüger ist in Carson wie ist die
Lage dort
also wir sind hier vor ungefähr zwei
Stunden in der Stadt angekommen und man
kann hier hinter mir eigentlich ganz gut
sehen wie das Wasser ganz langsam in die
Stadt hineinfließt wir sind hier einige
hundert Meter vom eigentlichen Flussbett
entfernt aber ich habe den Eindruck dass
im Moment erst ein kleiner Teil von
Carson überflutet worden ist im Grunde
ist die Situation hier relativ ruhig es
sind auch immer noch Menschen in der
Stadt den wir begegnet sind ich denke
wir müssen einfach noch abwarten wie
hoch das Wasser wirklich kommt und
welche Schäden dann wirklich hier
entstanden sind durch diese Sprengung
des Darms in der vergangene Nacht es
gibt keine unabhängigen Informationen
über diese Sprengung viele machen
Russland verantwortlich was spricht
dafür
das stimmt wir wissen nicht genau wer
diesen Damm gesprengt hat oder ob er
einfach nur zerstört worden ist aber
dieser Zeitpunkt zu dem der dann
zerstört worden ist natürlich schon
bemerkenswert wir haben hier in den
vergangenen zwei Tagen die ersten
nennenswerten
Offensivaktionen der ukrainischen Armee
entlang der Front gesehen und genau in
dieser Nacht wird dann dieser Damm
zerstört und jetzt vermutet natürlich
oder die ukrainische Seite geht fest
davon aus dass die russischen Russen
versuchen damit die Offensive zu
behindern dass Sie versuchen zu
verhindern dass über den Fluss hinweg
angegriffen wird aber wie gesagt wir
wissen es nicht genau der ukrainische
Präsident selenski hat allerdings schon
vor Monaten vor genau diesem Szenario
gewarnt was sie jetzt hier sehen er hat
damals gesagt sollte die russische Seite
in diesem Damm sprengen dann wäre das
eine Kriegserklärung an die gesamte Welt
und die ukrainische Seite hat jetzt ähm
im Tag im Laufe des Tages auch noch von
ganz anderen Sachen gewarnt nämlich von
den langfristigen Folgen nämlich vor den
ökologischen Folgen und auch von den
ökonomischen Folgen dieser engung des
Darms in der vergangenen Nacht danke
schön Tim Krüger live aus Herrn
zur Lage in der Ukraine nach der
Zerstörung des kachowa Staudamms gibt es
auch ein ZDF Spezial gleich im Anschluss
an diese heute Nachrichten
es ist die erste Reise eines deutschen
Verteidigungsministers nach Indien seit
acht Jahren Boris Pistorius wirbt in
Neu-Delhi für eine neue strategische
Partnerschaft ganz konkret geht es um
Rüstungsexporte etwa den
milliardenschweren Verkauf deutsche
U-Boote an das südasiatische Land bisher
ist Indien weitgehend von russischen
Waffenverkäufen abhängig Thomas Reichert
ist dabei
wie anders in den ist das merkt
Verteidigungsminister Boris Pistorius
gleich die Ehrenformation schreitet der
Gast hier stets allein ab bei 36 Grad
wartet sein indischer Kollege wie üblich
unterm Ball dahin die Härten im
Pistorius auf sich er wird im Indien
besonders um mehr rüstungszusammenarbeit
die Zurückhaltung bei beispielsweise der
Lieferung von Waffen und anderen
Material hat dazu geführt dass Indien
wie andere Länder auch sich sehr
orientieren mussten aus ihrer
Perspektive nach Russland z.B und jetzt
finden wir zusammen kommen rund 60% der
Waffen Indiens aus Russland deshalb
Putins Krieg gegen die Ukraine auch
deshalb bislang nicht verurteilt
historisches begleiten in Indien
Vertreter der deutschen
Rüstungsindustrie ein Vorvertrag über
den Bau von U-Booten von ThyssenKrupp
soll hier unterschrieben werden Indien
ist zunächst mal offen sie machen
Geschäfte mit nahezu allen Nationen
dieser Welt und ich glaube das ist gut
wäre wenn wir sie stärker auch an
Deutschland finden können zum Beispiel
mit solchen großen Auftritt andere
Maschinen in die gleiche Richtung zwei
Tage vor Pistorius erst war
US-Verteidigungsminister Lloyd Austin in
Indien da ging es um den Bau von
Maschinen für Kampfjets es ist schon ein
Kurswechsel nicht nur von Deutschland
sondern des Westens insgesamt bislang
war man bei Waffenlieferungen dann
Indien sehr zurückhaltend das hat sich
jetzt geändert und man ist viel eher
bereit die Wünsche zu erfüllen um Indien
mehr an sich zu binden und vor allem
nicht an Russland zu verlieren
zwei Nachrichten heute betreffen den
Inhaftierten russischen
oppositionelleni zum einen hat der
Europäische Gerichtshof für
Menschenrechte Russland verurteilt das
Land habe nach dem Giftanschlag gegen
nawalni unzureichend ermittelt unter
anderem sei ein politisches Motiv für
den Mordversuch nicht in Betracht
gezogen worden außerdem hat in Moskau
ein neuer Prozess gegen den
krimelkritiker begonnen wegen
angeblichem Extremismus drohen ihm
weitere 30 Jahre Lagerhaft
seit Jahren tritt die EU beim Asylrecht
auf der Stelle die geltenden Regeln
greifen nicht mehr und neue sind nicht
mehrheitsfähig bis jetzt übermorgen
wollen die EU Innenminister über ein
neues Regelwerk beraten zentraler Punkt
dabei an den Außengrenzen der EU soll es
vor Prüfungen für Asylanträge geben die
Bundesregierung signalisiert prinzipiell
Zustimmung doch die Basis der Grünen
meldet große Bedenken an
sie kommen aus Syrien Afghanistan oder
der Türkei die Zahlen steigen einen
härteren Kurs in der Migrationspolitik
will die EU-Kommission auch die
ampelregierung könnte damit gehen mehr
sichere Drittstaaten dazu beschleunigte
Asylverfahren an der EU-Außengrenze für
Sie denkbar nun ein Brandbrief an die
grüne Parteispitze von 730 Mitgliedern
auch wenn die Verhandlungssituation in
Brüssel sicherlich schwierig ist und wir
sicher sind dass ihr für die Umsetzung
des Koalitionsvertrags kämpft so ist es
doch schwer nachvollziehbar warum die
deutsche Verhandlungsposition nicht
annähernd den Inhalten des
Koalitionsvertrags entspricht das was
außengrenzverfahren konkret bedeuten
würden dass alle Menschen erstmal dort
für sechs Monate in Haft kommen dann
vielleicht grundsätzlich abgewiesen
werden das stellt ein Stück weit das
Grundrecht auf der südfrage und davor
warnen wir ganz deutlich es wäre eine
schärfere Gangart der Ampel
beschleunigte Verfahren bereits an der
Grenze bei Ablehnung würden Migranten
gleich zurückgeschickt Lager ähnliche
Zustände wie in Moria befürchtet die
Grünen Basis das grüne Spitzenpersonal
beschwichtigt wir werden am Ende einer
Vereinbarung zustimmen wenn sie
Humanität und Ordnung zusammenbringt und
wenn sie tatsächlich nicht das Asylrecht
aushüllt
Familien und Minderjährige von den
grenzverfahren ausgenommen werden für
Menschenrechtsorganisationen machen
Ausnahmen aber nichts besser
wir müssen auch das Grundproblem von
grenzverfahren nicht denn dort würden
weiterhin zum Beispiel
lgbtiq-menschen landen Menschen mit
extrem traumaerfahrung oder nach
sexualisierter Gewalt und all das kann
eben in grenzverfahren nicht richtig
erkannt und behandelt werden am
Nachmittag veröffentlicht der Spiegel
ein weiteres Schreiben mit deutlicher
Kritik an der geplanten asylreform 24
Bundestagsabgeordnete von Grünen und SPD
haben unterschrieben
Bundesumweltministerin Lemke will den
Druck auf Polen erhöhen die oder besser
zu schützen hintergrund ist die Lage im
Sommer vor einem Jahr und die
Umweltkatastrophe damals am
deutsch-polnischen Grenzfluss auf
polnischer Seite waren große Mengen Salz
ins Wasser geleitet worden weil sich
dadurch eine giftige Alge vermehrte
starben massenhaft Fische nach
Schätzungen etwa 360 Tonnen Jan Meyer
berichtet
die Bundesumweltministerin schlägt Alarm
auch gestern Abend ergaben Messungen im
Wasser der oder einen erhöhten
Salzgehalt genau der hatte im
vergangenen Sommer die Katastrophe
ausgelöst ich bin in Sorge dass die
salzeinleitung zu hoch sein könnten und
wenn dann wieder Hitze auftritt und die
Alge ja weiterhin im Fluss vorhanden ist
wie eine Wiederholung erleben könnten im
vergangenen August wurde der halbe
Fischbestand des artenreichen Flusses
getötet vergiftet durch die goldalge die
hatte sich plötzlich ausgebreitet weil
polnische Bergbaubetriebe stark
salzhaltiges Abwasser einleiteten
ausgerechnet zu einer Zeit als die oder
so wenig Wasser führte wie selten
zur Konferenz heute in Schwedt waren
auch Vertreter der Regierung aus
Warschau eingeladen gekommen sind nur
Umweltschützer und Lokalpolitiker
wir leben in Angst vor dem was sonst
noch passieren könnte dennoch immer
haben die Behörden nichts unternommen
die Schuldigen zu benennen ich fürchte
es bleibt dabei dass es keine
angemessene Reaktion geben wird
Baggerarbeiten am polnischen Ufer sogar
in der leicht Zeit Polen baut die oder
zur leistungsfähigen Wasserstraße aus
lässt den Fluss nicht zur Ruhe kommen
die Bundesumweltministerin fährt deshalb
morgen zu einem Treffen mit ihrer
polnischen Amtskollegin
rammstein ist eine der erfolgreichsten
deutschen Bands weltweit bejubelt doch
seit Tagen sorgt Sänger Till Lindemann
für Schlagzeilen es geht um
Machtmissbrauch am Rande von Konzerten
junge Frauen sollen für Sex mit dem
60-Jährigen ausgesucht worden sein
vielleicht auch mit KO-Tropfen die Band
selbst warnt vor Vorverurteilung
Familienministerin Pauls fordert
besseren Schutz der Frauen München zieht
Konsequenzen dort gibt Rammstein ab
morgen vier Konzerte Claudia Vogelmann
Rammstein steht für brachiale Musik und
sorgt seit Tagen für Schlagzeilen der
bentleder Till Lindemann wird mit
Vorwürfen konfrontiert er habe
KonzertbesucherInnen gezielt ausgewählt
um später mit ihnen Sex zu haben die
influencerin Color Sharks wurde auf
einem seiner Konzerte zu einer Party der
nach eingeladen und berichtet mir wurde
nicht gesagt dass ich hier gerade Teil
einer potenziellen Orgie werde wurde
gesagt ich gehe zu ganz normal auf der
Party ich habe sichergestellt da sind
auch andere Leute ja es ist eine normale
Party ist es hier nichts wurde mir davon
gesagt dass ich irgendwie mit einem
Umkleidekabine mit zwei couches und
Alkohol mit irgendwie von Tillmann
ausgesucht werden sollst weibliche Fans
sehen die vorderste Reihe in die
sogenannte Rose Zero gebeten wurden
sollen gezielt für Sex mit dem Band
Lieder rekrutiert worden sein die
irische influencerin scherbelin vermute
dass er auf einer Party der Band Drogen
verabreicht wurden diese Fotos sollen
belegen dass es zu Gewalt gekommen ist
bei einem Rammstein Konzert im Mai in
Vilnius die Band distanziert sich
beteiligt euch nicht an öffentlichen
vorurteilung jeglicher Art heißt es da
es gilt die Unschuldsvermutung auch im
Netz werden die Vorwürfe gegenüber der
Band Rammstein kontrovers diskutiert die
Stadt München fordert nun vom
Veranstalter Sicherheitsbereiche für
Frauen
derzeit gibt es hier keine
Rechtsgrundlage für eine Absage und
deswegen haben wir uns Gedanken gemacht
wie wir präventiv solche
Großveranstaltungen einfach für alle
sicherer machen können das bedeutet bei
den vier rammsteinkonzerten in München
wird es keine Reihe 0 für ausgesuchte
Fans und keine Aftershow-Party geben im
Olympiastadion wird bereits die Bühne
aufgebaut wie sich Rammstein hinter der
Bühne verhält steht nun im Fokus der
Öffentlichkeit
für Bahnreisende ändert sich ab morgen
einiges dann tritt eine neue
EU-Verordnung in Kraft bei Verspätungen
wird es einfacher auf andere
Bahnunternehmen umzusteigen zudem soll
es mehr Fahrradstellplätze geben fällt
ein Zug aus oder verspätet sich müssen
Bahnunternehmen keine Entschädigung mehr
zahlen wenn sie nichts dafür können
beispielsweise bei Naturkatastrophen
außerdem haben Kunden künftig nur noch
drei Monate Zeit ihr Geld
zurückzufordern bislang blieb ihnen
dafür ein Ja
sie gilt als Ikone des brasilianischen
bosanova jetzt ist die Sängerin Astro
Gilberto im Alter von 83 Jahren
gestorben
weltberühmt machte sie das Lied the girl
from Ipanema da wurde dafür wurde
Gilberto als erste Brasilianerin mit dem
Grammy ausgezeichnet
[Musik]
ja
absolut du liegst dir zu Füßen Freud und
Leid bei der Fußball-Bundesliga
Stuttgart bleibt erstklassig Hamburg der
HSV hat es wieder nicht geschafft nach
dem 0:3 im relegations Hinspiel folgte
gestern Abend die eins zu drei
Heimpleite im Rückspiel der VfB dagegen
wieder mit einem erstklassigen Auftritt
die Erstklassigkeit also mehr als nur
verdient
der VfB Stuttgart spielt weiter
Bundesliga
Dino dabei hatten sie gestern kurzzeitig
so etwas wie Hoffnung Kittel traf früh
nach der Pause hatte sich das alles dann
aber schnell erledigt Stuttgarts Mio
Doppel Torschütze für den VfB und in der
nachtspielzeit traf dann noch Silas
vielleicht war die Bürde insgesamt nach
dem Spiel dann auch in Sandhausen und
die ganzen Rückschläge die war erlitten
haben über die Saison hinweg vielleicht
zu groß riesen Kompliment dann an alle
ans Trainerteam an die Spieler an die
Fans dann an alle wir haben
Schulterschluss hinbekommen
Klassenerhalt dank Schulterschluss der
VfB feiert in Hamburg die
Erstklassigkeit
borussia Mönchengladbach hat einen
Nachfolger für seinen jüngst entlassenen
Trainer Daniel Farke gefunden Ex
Leverkusen Coach Gerardo silvane erhält
einen
3-Jahresvertrag vor einem Jahr hatte
sich Tennisspieler Alexander das wäre es
bei den French Open in Paris schwer
verletzt jetzt findet er am selben Ort
von Spiel zu Spiel zu alter Stärke
zurück gestern Abend ein souveräner
Einzug ins Viertelfinale
nach sie gegen den Bulgaren Gregor
Dimitrov hat Alexander Zverev bei seinem
Comeback in Paris sogar Chancen auf
seinen ersten Grand Slam Sieg ich bin
extrem glücklich ich bin zurück im
Viertelfinale in Paris und ich hoffe da
kommt noch mehr in drei Sätzen zeigte
Zverev souverän dass er zurück ist in
alter Form Satz 1 gewann er deutlich im
zweiten Satz verlor der Olympiasieger
zwar ein Aufschlagspiel doch er kämpfte
sich zurück machte 14 Punkte
nacheinander und gewann 6:4
Unruhe gab es um zverest Diabetes Typ 1
Erkrankung denn die Veranstalter
untersagten nehmen sich das
lebenswichtige Insulin vor den Augen der
Fans zu spritzen Satz 3 gewann dennoch
ungefährdet mit sechs zu drei und somit
das Match er trifft nun auch Außenseite
wäre aus Argentinien
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und zwar schon morgen Nachmittag das war
zum Sport drücken
sommerliche Aussichten mit einigen
schauen und Gewittern kommen gleich von
Katja horneffer Marietta Slomka begrüßt
sie um 9:45 Uhr heute journal wir danken
für Interesse und wünschen Ihnen noch
einen schönen Abend bis morgen auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend heute gab es viel Sonne aber
nicht nur Sonne in Schleswig-Holstein
gab es ein hochnebelfeld das löst sich
bald auf und zog westwärts weg von
Südosten kamen Wolken heran die brachten
Regen mit aber auch Schauer und Gewitter
das waren meist nur wenige Liter Regen
die da herunterkamen aber die Wolken
hatten den Effekt dass es kühl gibt hier
im Vogtland waren es nur 14 Grad
nördlich von Berlin wurden 28 Grad
erreicht heute Nacht sinken die
Temperaturen hier in der Mitte auf 14
Grad in Schleswig-Holstein geht's bis 6
Grad runter und auch heute Nacht bleibt
bei den dichteren Wolken im Nordosten da
fällt noch weitere Regen am Anfang
können noch einzelne Gewitter dabei sein
in der zweiten Nachthälfte bildet sich
in Bayern aber auch in
Schleswig-Holstein Nebel und wenn der
sich morgen aufgelöst hat dann scheint
die Sonne ganz im Norden und ganz im
Süden strahlend in der Mitte gibt's
dagegen mehr Wolken besonders am
Nachmittag über den Bergen kann es dann
einzelne Schauer und Gewitter geben bei
Wind aus nördlichen Richtungen das
merken sie wieder vor allen Dingen an
der Nordsee denn da bleibt es bei 16
Grad kühl an der Küste und auch rund um
die Mittelgebirge liegen die
Temperaturen wenig über 20 Grad bis zu
28 Grad geht's wieder nördlich von
Berlin am Donnerstag gibt's dann einige
Unwetter Freitag und Samstag beschränken
sich die Gewitter auf den Südosten heute
Abend